all right ladies and gentlemen uh
welcome to the podcast my long
time friend uh comedian writer
producer actor uh the very funny
uh but like i say most importantly my
friend mr momento welcome to the podcast
welcome to riffing with griffin we tried
it before because you have your let's
just talk about the fun stuff first uh
because you have your project on the
discovery channel right
yeah i had um a special slash pilot that
aired
may 20th called small town throwdown can
you
can people still see it is it on their
website is it on the on demand
yeah it's on uh if you go to discovery
go it's like they're
that's their app you can watch it yeah
yeah and i think it came out great man
it's been like the best feedback of
anything i've ever done it's like this
hour-long comedic travel show that like
shines a light on
notorious towns around america with bad
reputations
and now we're just kind of sitting here
like do they want to do more episodes
can they do more episodes how do you do
a travel show
where a comedian goes into bars and
right you know sporting events
in a place where you can't apparently be
around people which makes it difficult
so yeah you know it's kind of it's kind
of weird right that um
like when you look back in history of
like major events that have happened in
the world
and how the entertainment business still
thrived you know
like dude like all the depressions we
hear about you know you always hear
about well hollywood still survived or
even in the housing crash it was like
you know people still came out to shows
and people still needed entertainment
this is the first thing that in my
lifetime
being a lot you know uh that you're like
well no you can't do
anything like that that's a real i mean
that's a really good point it's kind of
like
the two constants are like entertainment
and liquor sales
yeah right because no matter how bad
life is people need escape but yeah like
right now
that i think is what's so crippling
about this virus
is that even if people aren't mentally
sick from it i mean aren't physically
sick
mentally there's a lot of sickness
because people are just like hold away
from each other all their usual ways of
coping with life
are gone i mean for comedians look we
can't we can't perform
right yeah it's a real you know the
other day i did uh i was i told i just
had fahim on the podcast for him anwar
and i just had i just did a comedy show
in la it was like outdoors
oh yeah yeah i saw you promoting that i
think they're even doing it at the
comedy store actually i think they're
doing like they're setting up chairs in
the parking lot of the comedy store
and they're just like having an outdoor
they're trying to do an outdoor show
so i did this crazy outdoor show like if
you see the pictures i'm on a
bed of a pickup truck and you know
there's weird people
spread out in the crowd but man it was
so cathartic i just was like oh i missed
this so much and you know
so i mean i i think that we'll find a
way but just the the the logistics of it
and the business of it is different now
yeah and i mean and we're just talking
about for creators but i mean for like
just the average person right you go to
work you're dealing with your kids
you're dealing with your wife or your
husband or whatever
and then here comes friday night and
just like the chance to be around
strangers in a restaurant like that is
somehow cathartic you know it somehow
makes you feel connected to humanity
in a way that we don't have now and
unfortunately instead of that what we
have is
connection to social media which is as
toxic as it's ever been
yeah and it's sort of just like it's a
very
yeah it's a really weird it's i was
telling uh ashley my fiance today like
i remember like the other significant
moment in my life
where something like this was like 911
and like you know all the all the
terrorism
fears and everything that america was
going through and how that really
brought america together and yet i feel
like right now
this is a moment where the whole world
is sort of dealing with something
and i feel like things are more divided
than they've ever been
in a couple lifetimes probably yeah in
my life yeah i guess
it's weird how politicized that they're
using this virus
you know at what point like the the the
the
downside and the upside to the
coronavirus is one
the mortality rate um but actually if it
was like
ebola they would have already contained
it already because
people died right away there's no it's
just like so those are the kind of
diseases that you think
oh my god if ebola breaks out it's like
you know that's not the one you got to
worry about because they could stop that
if people get sick they know they're
going to die that stops it right there
you know with this one it's like
you know the death rate is not the death
rate is terrible
but it's at this point right now it's
it's on par with like regular flu
well it's it's so confusing right it's
so state to state
because i'm here in portland and like
yeah like there is
the the rates are going up but the
hospitalization rates as far as i can
see aren't all that crazy but then my
fiance is a doctor and a friend of hers
out in florida
who works at a hospital said this is
[__] bananas like literally the
icu was completely jammed everybody in
here is coved and it's craziness
where she works in hospitals in portland
and that's not at all the case but you
know so uh-huh go ahead
no i'm just going to say if it's like
you're saying there's like very strong
realities
but different realities uh you know
which which
and like literally the guy i just did
comedy myself and i was working with a
comedian who
is in a conspiracy sam tripley and his
belief about what's going on is
completely different than mine
and the only thing i felt uncomfortable
about during the weekend was the fact
that we were talking backstage he wasn't
wearing a [__] mask because he thinks
it's all
a hoax right right right and it's you
know and those
type of people are the people that
like you go okay fine and then
those people get sick you know and then
all of a sudden it's not a hoax
because because i i have a new numerous
friends now that have come down with it
and they've gotten
really sick that you know they felt you
know but it's like they've gotten really
sick where it's like
okay it's a really bad cold you know
like it's the fever
they you know when you know i've had
regular colds where i've been in bed
like oh my god i think i'm gonna die
you know because i mean that's the thing
that's the thing like i was saying
like and by the way i love sam tripoli
and i love all this crazy conspiracy
stuff but that's what i was kind of
saying to him like
even if you are right where like if we
get it we're not gonna die
like there's a [__] flu or something
going around like crazy right now a
virus
i don't want to get that [__] like it
sucks to be sick dude it sucks
and so then also if you have to worry
that maybe you're going to give it to
someone who's not as fortunate as you
are to be young and you know relatively
young and healthy
that's scary too yeah i mean the the the
tricky thing about this particular virus
and what we're asking people to do
to help combat it the problem is people
are [__] selfish
like oh like it's like everything you
everything you have to do to help stop
this virus
is for you to be inconvenienced to help
everyone else
and [__] don't want to do that
so that's absolutely
annoying yeah i'm so annoyed on facebook
where you see people being like
look the truth is if i don't want to be
afraid of this
and i'm not afraid then i shouldn't have
to be they're taking my rights like dude
how many times do they have to say it
this is about
other people yeah you know it's really
it's so dumb
it's like someone's saying hey man i am
good at drinking and driving
and i don't care if i die in a car
accident yeah but you might
[__] kill other people while you're
doing it i mean it's like
i don't know why that is so difficult
for people to understand but i guess the
reality is
if there's one trait that all human
beings have
in abundance and in common it's being
incredibly selfish
and not really being able to put
yourself in the next guy's shoes yeah
i agree because but the thing too about
the it's actually even more nuanced when
it comes to this virus is because
so what you said about the your your
your your fiance's
situation with her friend in florida see
the problem is not even about the virus
affecting people
it's about straining the medical system
so it's like
they're saying yes it's fine that not a
lot of people necessarily die
but a lot of people get sick and need
medical care and if all of us get sick
at once
we won't have the resources to help
everybody
that people could die needlessly so
that's the part that people
so so this is what i'm saying is like
they're right
so like both sides are right so the
people that are like uh this is not that
serious
um you know i'm not a lot of people are
dying okay
you might be right and then on the other
side we're saying yeah i get that but
the problem is
enough people are getting sick that
they're that it's straining the medical
we don't want the
if there's only three million beds in
the in the united states
you know and 50 million people get sick
what are we gonna do
but but i actually don't think you're
that's quite right because
while people would say well look the
hysteria doesn't match the death rate
look a hundred and thirty thousand
people have died from this depending on
if you believe that's dislike right yeah
how many people does the flu kill every
year i think it's 200
no it's it's like 200 000 okay in a year
right
so this is a lot four months you know i
can look it up right now i don't think
it's that much but even if it is just
think about this
this is in within four months and the
whole [__] world has shut down
yeah like nothing like this has ever
happened so we were like it's not as bad
as i said i'm like
yeah dude people aren't going to [__]
work like i'm interacting with one
person
on a weekly basis and i'm not like going
to coffee shops it's like
it's a lot of death rates considering
what would it have been like if we
hadn't shut down
obviously like 12 times as high yeah
that's my that's my thought
and what do you see in there it's in
2019 to 2020 okay oh yeah this was a
smaller one yes like
between flu deaths 24 000 to 62
000. right in a year and it's 130 000
and we've shut down
but i've seen other ones where it was
like wait it was way more yeah well
that's on samtripoli.com yeah
but even still but like flu
hospitalizations
in 2019 to 2020 is seven
between 400 and 10 thousand and seven
hundred and forty thousand
i know i heard that too and i was like
[__] are going to the hospital
with the flu
yeah well that's again though check it
out that's also what's happening
there's a little bit of a see what i'm
saying is why everybody's right is there
is a little bit of hysteria
you know like if you have a sniffle you
think you're going to die of covid and
you're going to the hospital i
absolutely you know so
i've played that game for sure yeah um
there is something there
you know yeah yeah i don't know it's
it's just like a depressing time to be
alive that's for sure
it's like it's it's like
and the reality is like when people are
saying like oh we opened too soon you
know
which i think is true on a scientific
level i well look at this there's like
four states that i saw a thing on the
news today actually today talking about
this that there are
four states that have beat the curve
that that are trending down
because of what they did connecticut is
one of them because yeah they start they
man
mandated that everybody has to wear
masks they didn't open
right away they waited two two extra
months before they decided to open and
now
they're they're fighting it you know
right the problem is it's just so
hard for us to do it i mean i even feel
myself you know
like i'll try to wear a mask all the
time actually it's so funny like
my fiance comes home and we only have
like one like door thing so i got to
come down let her out of the garage
and uh usually i get in the elevator
with a mask and then when i let her down
this morning i didn't put one on
and then some guy got in the elevator
without a mask and i was like this close
to being like hey dude
don't get in the [__] elevator if
you're not gonna have a mask and like as
it was about to come out of my mouth i'm
like i'm not wearing a mask i'll just
shut the [__] up
um i yeah the mask thing i hate it but
here's the thing about the masks
okay the masks are like when your mom
asked you to make your bed when you were
a kid
it's [__] annoying okay oh it's
annoying yeah but you know you do it but
what i'm saying is
people telling you to put on a mask they
got to remember that [__]
like i was at the i was at the coffee
i pulled up to the coffee bean drive
through i'm in a drive-through
okay you know and i'm glad to pick him
up and the guy
slams the door shut and he's just
banging on the the glass
cuz you know you have to put on a man
you know the way he did it i was like
go [__] yourself okay yeah yeah i'm just
saying just the way he approached it i
was like i get it
but you're also being a [__]
you know what i mean 100 percent you
know i'm just saying like it's like hey
that's the double that's the hard part
about it like a double-edged sword about
it right
like have you ever have you ever walk in
a dog and like the dog takes a [__] and
you're like
[__] i don't have any bags and you just
kind of try to leave it and someone
comes up to you and it's like
pick that up and you're like yeah i hate
when those dogs are on the ground too
but still
[__] you yes man that's exactly i've
picked up a thousand
dog shits in my life one slides and
you're gonna [__] make me feel like
um
charles manson it's really challenging
yeah
interpersonal communication and how
people
you know like i'm saying i'm not saying
like yes you have every right like if
you're at a business place you're like
hey you can't come in here
unless you have a mask i mean there's i
just feel like there's a way to approach
it that like
i don't think it helps like all i'm
saying is this
it doesn't help that you're being a
[__] [__]
when you're asking people to put on a
mask like like the picture this house
you're right but would you want do you
want to be right
or do you want to have a better
situation that's happening right now
like right it's not the it's not the
end-all be-all
and it's also like i love seeing this in
myself
the hypocrisy of when i'm willing to be
right like
the couple i was in the elevator with
ashley in a couple and like one time
some guy came in the elevator i was like
hey man
like this is early days of kobe when i
was really really trying to do
everything i was like hey man
can you just wait for another elevator
you know i was nice about it like he
just wait and he's like uh
okay and he waited she was like wow i've
never seen you do that before
and then like i've got a week later like
a girl tried again i was like hey you
know if you don't mind i was like so i
was like
what i do and then like three weeks
later like some enormous dude
with tats came in and i was like yeah
i'm just gonna hold my breath i'm gonna
get out you come in you know
yeah it's so weird no that would have
even taken more balls i didn't want to
offend him i was just like
oh and she was and she was looking at me
like yeah when you say something
now i mean it's like but that's what i'm
saying you know but that
but being that whole thing about being
right is like i've learned that more
about because
as i get more serious in in my
relationship
in my relationship you know you know and
it's like you realize
oh yeah you being right in a
relationship
is pointless like you know it doesn't
mean anything it literally means nothing
like you have to it's more about like do
you want to be right or do you want to
have a good relationship
yeah i remember you saying that on the
phone the other day when we were kind of
mutually sort of
going into our relationship stuff and
it's definitely true i mean it's
it's god you got to just like check that
little [__]
ego part of your brain that wants to
prove yourself
and feels like a victim if you're not
being heard and then you have to just be
like
[__] it you know this idea of this idea
of fairness too is you have to get rid
of that too you got to get rid of the
idea of fairness like
it's like if i watch 10 of her idiotic
shows
okay like we're watching every every
housewife show
just put a city i'm [__] watching it
okay but but be honest with yourself
are you enjoying them a little bit more
than you thought you would oh yeah
oh wait wait yeah yeah yeah but i'm
enjoying him in a way where i'm like i
like to hate watch i'm like
these [__] are awful you know
whatever you know
whatever it is but i'm saying it's like
like you know this is what me about
fairness
i can watch 10 of those shows and then
and i go can we just watch
one of my you know like wow i i'm
i am so luckily in the opposite we have
watched nothing but van damme movies and
[__]
sword fight and the other day she made
me watch
this british show and i was like oh is
this what it's like for you to watch my
[__] all the time
because i am miserable yeah yeah there's
a show called poldark
and then we i ended up [__] falling
in love with it we watched six seasons
of it here's the thing too though i i i
lose my mind
i let it go i actually literally don't
care anymore
i literally don't care i just i just go
what you know what are you watching okay
boom and then like you know she goes to
work and i turn on my my shows
you know but the other thing is like we
have different tastes too so like you
know that's just one thing
you just go okay when you have different
tastes from someone like you know she
doesn't like violence at all
if there's at that point it's like i
can't watch anything then yeah it's
pretty much that's all i like to watch i
know so what something
you just go okay you watch that i just
put my ipad put my headphones on
you know hold her hand while she's
watching her thing and then that doesn't
piss her off
i hate when she watches something mine
and she's on twitter that makes me well
angry no we have we work it out because
she if she knows i don't want to watch
this it
mean it is what it is bro you know it is
what it is but you know i want her to
fake
i want her to fake the orgasm of
enjoying the shows i'm making her watch
i need her to pretend like she really
enjoys blood sport
nobody's like i need her to sell it but
you know i think about sometimes i i
realized the other day because i
actually have some like i did something
the other day um rachel's grandma is in
like
a retirement home in florida and she
can't go out and she can't see people so
her family every sunday does a zoom call
you know with like so there's seven or
eight nine ten people
and they zoom and her grandma loves it
and what the what her rachel's family
has done is
everybody makes a video for and they
play it on the zoom call like so it'll
be like a theme like
the last theme was like everybody's
makes a cup of coffee the way they make
coffee and they played it for
the grandma and she made so rachel was
at work and she wasn't on the call so i
had all
i was on the call and all her family's
there like her immediate family
so while on the zoom call i said hey
guys i have a can i ask you guys
you know a question you know it's her
mom her dad or grandma all the important
people in her life and i was like
i have intentions of uh of of asking
rachel to
wow my wife and i just want to know that
if you guys are okay with that you know
it was like so nerve-wracking and like
you know it was like i was like
nervous but i thought this is the only
way you could do it right now
you know you know it's like i can't
necessarily go to her you know
her parents house i mean you know you
know i don't want to get down you know i
mean i already had like a scare where i
went and got a
coveted test and i came back negative
but like any little thing you're like
you know oh my god am i so something up
so but anyways
you know so i'm at that point in a
relationship now and it's just
but like i said what i've realized is
like i've just let a lot of things go
that i would not have let go before you
know like so i i like i feel like
i'm the comp a whole restaurant and
rachel's the customer
you know you know what i mean and like
so i'm the sh
i'm the chef the waiter the bush boy
she's got you uh yeah in a good place
but don't leave us in suspense
what did they say oh everybody was they
were good her mom and dad called me
after
oh yeah i should tell you that yeah it
was great everybody had a great response
her grandma called rachel later and was
like
i'm so happy and all this kind of stuff
so i thought you're going to say they
said no so now i got to get covet and
ask him again in person i know i was
like hello i know
for real dude no but it worked out it
was working out great i did the same
thing with my uh with my fiance's
parents and
such a funny thing because like i always
kind of thought like
what if they say no yeah what are you
supposed to do i'm still gonna do it
yeah yeah that's what i know exactly
what you mean
it's like oh this is a formality
like oh let me make it clear i don't
give a [__] what you think
like i'm not getting back on tinder
because you don't like me yeah yeah yeah
it is it is what it is uh dude so let me
tell you this is such a funny thing that
just happened to us
so like two months ago we were like just
like
the girl next door was playing her music
super loud and it was just like
really like just during the day and i
could take i'll take a nap like every
day so it's like this is [__]
annoying you know you just heard it
so finally finally after like three
weeks i was like all right i gotta go
over there you know so
i went and asked her can you guy can you
please keep it down
and she came in super hot and she's like
i can hear you guys having sex
and i was like oh okay you know i
like i mean i didn't expect that you
know so now i'm just like well what did
you hear
you know what i mean like like what kind
of [__] like what do i sound like when
i'm having sex like it sounds depressing
that's what
yeah exactly unfulfilling that's what it
sounds like
it sounds like one person's jogging and
the other person's making no noise at
all hey buddy that's probably but dude
by the way if you can hear her music of
course she can hear you
i didn't think about it like that i
didn't i didn't know you know and then i
was like i mean i don't think i'm
talking out of turner i don't think
ashley would mind me saying this and
it's not because of me
she's loud she is loud you know i mean
she's one of the louder women i've ever
been with by far
like she's just that's how she she gets
down with it right so
i was like said to her i'm like we got
to be quiet you know what i mean
we have to start being quiet and sure
enough she started being quieter in
music
we started having sex quieter started
having sex with her and then it got down
to there was no sound
at all and we thought she moved right so
we were like she moved because we don't
ever see her
and we never saw her before but we don't
hear any music it's it's gone from
really bad to perfect right over the
weekend
we had sex and ashley was super loud
the next day bam music right back up by
the way
by the way for like three days and i was
like fair play no no but what i'm saying
is now what you're realizing is the
music was loud because of you
that was her it wasn't like this rude
lady is like i'm gonna play my music no
she was like
i'm tired of hearing sad sex
but what speaking of sad i said to her i
was like when she said i don't
i don't hear you guys having sex i
wasn't thinking i go oh we don't hear
you having sex
dude what are you doing i wasn't trying
to be a dick i was just sort of like
trying to clarify
she's like somebody that you would look
and go that person probably doesn't have
a lot of sex
so i was like i was like oh so you're
just putting on loud music and dancing
alone
are you rude and disrespectful well
anyways
um look uh one of the reasons why i
for the people watching why i had mo
come on the program is uh mo
is one of my uh friends and one of my
jewish american friends and
uh this uh last few days there was a big
dust up in the
uh in the universe in the twitter
universe with nick cannon
i don't you know he was on i think it
was his podcast right
yeah i was on his podcast canon's class
and he had uh
professor griff from public enemy who um
was kicked out of public enemy in 1989 i
believe
because of rumors of or saying
anti-semitic things oh even back
actually because i listened to nick can
i listen to the whole podcast today
which was brutal and i did not want to
listen to it
um because you know
i you know what he was saying was
hurtful and i didn't like
hearing him say that so this is the rest
of what we're getting at right now but
you're skipping over let's let's
just no no no it's fine yeah so nick
hannibal had
and and and since then he's there's been
repercussions he's
i think he was dropped from cbs uh you
know i think
viacom fired him fired him and uh you
know he
you know he's getting a lot of flack on
twitter and all this kind of stuff and
and i know just you hit me up because
you were just like you know i can't
believe this and
especially on the heels of right now a
lot of changes happening in the world
you know
uh from the from the george floyd
incident the murder of george floyd and
then all the protests and everybody
talking about black lives matter
a lot of things have happened like the
reds washington redskins changed them
they're changing their name
right you know great so so so it has to
carry over into all walks of life
and uh and this is what you were upset
by this
being jewish yourself and and the
comments so you have
you know feelings about it and so now
we're everybody's caught up it's
it started like you know like
about a month ago i think it was ice
cube was tweeting all kinds of like you
know
stuff about the racial uh things going
on america
as he should and as everyone should of
all walks of life should as i did
as you did as everybody did because look
the sentiment black lives matter
is something that i and anyone with a
brain
can say with their in complete heart and
conviction
you know what i mean everyone can get
behind that
i any let me put this away anyone i want
to know
can get behind the sediment of black
lives matter 100 and if you can't i
don't want you in my life i don't want
to know you right
so it was this part where it was kind of
like i was watching something with
ashley on
the news and they were showing how
people had put a a mural of george floyd
in yemen [__] yemen you know what i
mean so it's like this beautiful moment
where it's like
people are like this is [__] these
people are being treated like [__] these
people are being killed
and we need to come together and the
world stood up right and in the middle
of that ice cube tweets out some [__]
jewish conspiracy theory [__]
you know and it's just like whoa that's
a weird thing to do
when i everyone i know
jewish not jewish is echoing support as
they should
for this movement right so it's weird
and what was even weirder was just being
like
there's not any repercussions for that
right like none at the same time when
we're living in a world
where anyone could have said something
15 years ago and if it comes out
they're fired right and so ice cube says
that
none no apology guys like even um what's
his name who's that jewish guy who's a
sports
ranter comedian michael uh robert it was
a
rap report he even kind of came out he
even came out and defended ice cube
which was sort of like
okay all right so then like flash
forward like three weeks later
chelsea handler uh tweets out
a 10-minute video of louis farrakhan on
the donahue show in the 1970s right
it's a 10-minute clip i watched the
whole thing she said this actually makes
a lot of sense to me
right i watched it makes tons of sense
it's a really
really well put description of racism in
america
really really well put the problem is
louis farrakhan has said
incredibly horrible things about jews
and gays
so for chelsea handler a jew to say hey
this makes a lot of sense that's like me
saying hey
eric did you hear what hitler said about
uh tariffs on
imported goods it's really smart his
tariff strategy oh i guess he's done
some other stuff too but i'm not going
to focus on so for someone like chelsea
handler who since
apparently apologized to this but she
says oh look at this great thing louis
farrakhan says and then the next day she
says
i guess there was some lgbtq thing that
passed in the in the um
in the government and she's like isn't
this great i'm like yeah it is you know
who wouldn't think it's great
[__] louis farrakhan like at all like
would hate it right so
it's just yeah anyway no no no no i get
i hear you right now and i just want to
go i want to bounce off of you right now
because yeah because like i i know you
very well and i've never i i'm sorry i
don't mean to write i don't mean a rant
though it's a sort of like
i feel right it's fine i feel like
emotionally hurt by this stuff yeah
that's what i'm saying so
let me finish let me get let me get to
it yeah yeah that's what i'm saying so
i've
i've known you a long time and you know
usually when we do things like this
you're in like this like
really obnoxious performer mode and uh
now you're in like right now this is
like i could tell
well [__] you i'm just suck my dick now
let's get begging
i'm just saying it just needs to be a
100. so right now i can tell that you're
very
much this very much is is uh touched you
it's very much has uh upset you and
moved you because
i get the sentiment of it i feel is hey
we're talking about black lives matter
because to me what black lives matter
it's not just about black people
it's it's it's uh you know it represents
because the word that's missing from it
is two it's black lives matter too
right and then you can extrapolate that
to jewish lives matter
indian lives matter you know that's the
whole point the
point we're trying to say is like you
know that's that's the
it's it's the principle that matters the
principle
equality right equality and that's
the beauty of this movement that what
everyone could get behind
these lives matter these lies matter
because equality matters
so when people then say well
[__] those guys you're like so you don't
even believe in the
you don't even really believe in
equality yeah you you just want
things to be better for your group right
because then who can get behind that
that's just humanity's problem in a
nutshell right so
and you don't as a jewish person you
feel that the jews have just been
like you know passed over like hey what
you know hey hello what about uh
all these all these anti-semitic things
that are being said let's let's have
some outrage for that too
right okay yeah i'm gonna make it very
clear i'm not saying jews have been
passed over in terms of civil rights
equality
anything like that i'm just saying it
seems to be this weird
thing that i can't explain why then you
had desean jackson the guy for the
the eagles who i mean somehow still has
a job
even though he instagrammed a quote of
[__]
hitler of hitler
and it turned out it wasn't even hitler
he was incorrect it was something
so it's like it's just so weird to me
that at this time period
why do these things keep coming out
right it's really weird and then nick
cannon decides to
for who knows why at this moment in
history decides this is a good time
to talk about amongst a lot of other
stuff he said
that jews control everything and jews
are actually jews and it's like
why would this be the moment to do that
right and not to mention a lot of what
nick can say you should let's do it you
know it's all about how like
white people are savages because we're
jealous uh
that we don't have melanin and that
makes us unable to be compassionate
and that's why we want to kill it's like
it's like
literally hearing sam tripoli describe
to me why you shouldn't wear a mask
because this
rare source that he's quoting it's just
conspiracy theory nonsense and
unfortunately it sounds like someone
if you listen to it make up your own
mind but it sounds to me like a guy
who's read a lot of louis farrakhan a
lot of different people and is sort of
like piecing these things together
without realizing and this is what um
quite a few
writers have come out with jameel hill
wrote a great article about it which is
like
these are like things that have been
used these kind of conspiracy sort of
eugenic c
theories are exactly what's been used to
propagate white supremacy
yeah and to subjugate black people so
it's like why would you
in a million years take those horrible
horrible ideals and then flip them
and right now it's just kind of anyway
so karim al dujubar wrote an incredible
article that came out a couple days ago
where he basically called that ice cube
and it was just like what the [__] like
why are people doing it like this is not
the time for that and this
and he said something that i think is
really really true and dangerous he said
if people
don't call out all types of injustice
we're gonna get an apathy
towards injustice in general where
everybody's group is gonna be like i
don't care about that group
because they don't care about my group
and that's a really really sad
scary um
thing that could happen if people don't
tread lightly well one of the things
that i've been thinking about because of
this
is um you know like if i said to you
like
what do we all have in common and i'm
like well we're all human
so because we're all human we should
think this way
like you would find that ridiculous i
think most people would find that
ridiculous to think that
we're all human beings so we we all
think the same we know that that's not
true
we don't all think the same well
i we don't and yet we do like i would
say
99.9 percent of the way we think and
feel
is the same but you know i know about
priorities and everything i know but
what i'm saying though is that
but we but it's not because it's not
just
simply because we're human beings you
know it's like
you know that when you look at if when
you look at like why are we similar
we're similar the human beings wouldn't
even be the first thing that we would
mention
like if i said like how are you and i
the same we
you know we wouldn't even count human
beings because it's so right
it's such a common right what i'm trying
to say is
i don't understand we don't harp on
being a human being
like a lot we don't we don't that we
don't make that the thing we use in
arguments
yeah but the second and third thing that
separates us
are the things that we harp on the most
and to me that's ridiculous
because you got we're human beings the
next thing the next distinction we have
is
male or female and then we have
race yeah if the first thing that we
have in common
isn't enough to say we're the same
why would the second two be enough
for us to be like oh well all
males you know it's like it's like
during it's like the metoo movement when
somebody's like
like toxic masculinity as if all men
feel the same way
and it's like well no just like all
human beings don't feel the same way
just because we're human
all males don't feel the same way all
jewish males don't feel the same way
all jewish males over five foot i mean
when you start to really go
to the things that make us different
it's crazy that we lump people in
in groups that's the part i'm trying to
get at like like lumping everybody in in
a group
that is so broad right and the way that
nick cannon you know he was saying this
stuff where
you know he's alluding to these
long-term you know conspiracies that
jews control everything right but what i
don't ever understand
as a jew which i've never understood is
people say
jews control the world right and you say
well what does that mean and they bring
up these things that to be honest
with you i don't have i haven't
researched i don't know the names
rothschild outside of conspiracy
theorists i don't really know what that
means
but let's just let's just even let's
just even go a million let's just give
give nick cannon the ultimate
hypothetical that
and this is completely hypothetical
because i know nothing about this as far
as i know this is not true but
uh like some jews control some
businesses in the world
big ones right uh-huh but give them give
them that right how come
he doesn't say oh well the world's
controlled by the raw styles and those
guys and those guys
right why does he say the jews that's
wrong i i never heard anyone say
catholics molest kids i've never heard
that you know what i've heard
[__] those catholic priests those
guys and that guy and then another one
over there
molest kids no one's ever like catholics
are molesting
the kids you know what i mean it's
[__] weird i don't know why
it gets turned on jute like this overall
jewish thing
that is just like if you're a jew like
me who's like i've been around plenty of
jewish people plenty of roger
i've never heard one person describe one
thing conspiracy
webby [__] ever right it's just like
it's just it's so it's so dangerous
because most people
haven't been around a lot of different
like jews are a small percentage of the
population a lot of people haven't met a
lot of jews so if all they're hearing is
celebrities saying these [__] crazy
conspiracy theories guess what they're
gonna think i mean it's just like it's
not
rocket science well see this is exactly
what i'm saying like that's exactly my
point is like we like to put
people we like to put people that
we they have a certain thing in common
and all of a sudden
everybody we we make it everybody
like you said like you know we don't say
all catholics you know but
that's what we do with everything if
something happens we go well you know
women
we go oh well men you know and then
we're attacking these groups right now
all the time it's like it's like when
they were saying all black people are
lazy black people this black people that
it's all these things that they have and
it's like he actually boils down to like
it actually like you know economics and
social
social sociology and stuff have more to
do with why people think and do the
things they do
other than just the basics of i'm a man
i'm this race
you know you know what i mean in terms
of you know we should look at
that kind of intellectualization that
nick cannon
and people of that ilk of that way of
thinking
describe it and by that elk i mean
people on all races you know everybody
who groups people like that right yeah
let's just look at in the joke writing
situation if i hear you go up on stage
and tell a joke about
this one time that you dealt with this
specific ex-girlfriend and then she did
this weird like specific thing right
that jokes can be very interesting if i
hear you go up there and say
women are like this you know what that
strikes me as lazy
and [__] kind of like hacky right
it's the same way when you talk about
these groups of it's hacky it's lazy and
it's incorrect
you know and in this day and age it's
actually just dangerous
you know it's actually just dangerous
and i really i i feel like that
i feel that you feel
you're more upset about it because
you're sitting here as a
as a logical human being as a caring
human being and going like
hey the black lives matter has moved me
i have i've
like you said i've put up posts i'm
someone that agrees with this
and then for people who are who are very
vocal and loudmouth to just
say whatever they want willy-nilly about
jews it's like i don't think they
understand the point of
their own they don't even understand the
point and how it actually has an effect
i mean that like look how it's it struck
you it struck a chord with you
because of everything that is going on
you know like like normally you might
have been like oh here's some more
here's some more ducks you know but now
you're like hey wait a minute guys how
can you say this right now
well you know what it is for me and i
don't mean to come across
like hey i put up a post about black
lives matter
i you know support black lives matter
you have to support you know what i mean
i'm not trying to say this about no no
no no
this is more like a matter of
oh i thought we were i thought this was
about equality and togetherness exactly
and see
and also it's like a it's and it's like
a disappointment actually because
i just like i'm just flat out confused
i i see people on my timeline right
and and they are so vocal about black
lives matter and they're so vocal about
as they should be as they 100 should be
and yet i see they don't [__] say
[__]
about these things you know they don't
or even worse they say oh looks like
they took nick cannon down guess who
oh because he said they have the power
now they fired him it's like
jesus dude like how am i supposed it's
like this is what kareem
uh he you know kareem's article he
quoted a writer i believe her name was
roxanne gay
and he and she said she had tweeted ice
cube if you say these things
then it's impossible to take anything
you say about social justice seriously
and that's the reality right you know
once people
don't like we don't want to get this
country any more than already is into a
quid pro quo thing right
where democrats are like hey black
people we do stuff for you so you have
to support
us and republicans like no black people
we do stuff for you you have to support
us that's what they do
of course it's [__] gross that's
exactly what they do
yeah and it's incredibly gross you know
and
and it's just like just like it's also
just weird for me you know
because as a human being i come from
such an
untraditional place like grew up in a
[__] dirt road in the middle of the
country
there were no jews around you know what
i mean so i feel like i have like a
unique
position to kind of feel like i'm sort
of you know i'm able to see things in a
very
you know different kind of way because i
didn't grow up like around one type of
people
you know and like i can honestly say
like
to me what that says is i'm a jew if
you're a black guy who grew up
in the 80s in the bronx where
my dad lived in the 60s and then moved
out of and then black people moved in
and who knows i don't know maybe jewish
people own the buildings there now i
don't know so maybe you had a bad
experience with a landlord there
i can honestly say because i think
that's how a lot of like racial kind of
theories come people have like one
experience
and they're like that's what those
people are like you know what i mean i'm
just guessing
i'm just guessing where does someone
like where does a guy like professor
griff
hate jews right where or if he does
which he claims he doesn't although
there's a track record there i haven't
looked into it because i can't [__]
deal with all this [__]
but say i could say hey i'm jewish too
and so is that guy and we're not the
same guy as that guy and that guy's on
the same at that that's my point
you're not the same as that guy in
chicago who shot that guy and i
would never want to [__] think you
were and god forbid people in this world
start thinking
that everybody is the worst person right
in a particular group of people that's a
stupid way to look at everybody in a
really depressing way to go through life
yes i totally agree with you man that's
exactly my point i was trying to make is
that we are
way more different than we really think
and it's like you can't just use
the you can't use the top three things
the first three things on the list that
make everybody the same
we're human we're male or female and
then whatever our race is those are the
top three
those are the those are the when you're
when you're when you had a list of you
have to describe
how everyone is like that's going to be
the first three
that's not enough to to determine
people's you know how they are it's not
enough to determine their morality it's
not enough to determine like
how they think it's just one section so
the fact that we use that
we use those things so much those are
the things we go to all the time where
it's like
all men are toxic or all women are crazy
or like you know
it's just it's you know whatever we
these things that we say
it it is dangerous like not as comics
you know we use generalization sometimes
because it's for effect you know it's
like it's funny and
whatever we're doing but like this is
like real life going on this is like
it's affecting people like people's
words have
yeah effect and that's something i've
thought about in my own comedy you know
like coming up when i did like saying
whatever the [__] you wanted saying
offensive [__] was like i thought it was
hilarious and that was basically
and it's sort of like yeah i have a i'm
i'm at a loss with how i feel about
how i feel about it you know i don't i
don't think it's
i don't think it's okay to do because it
clearly affects people
yeah well i mean it's like you know but
again with jokes it's like it's so it's
a weird
it's a fine line a tricky one because
like that just makes you write that just
makes people have to write
better you have to write better jokes
like i look at some of the jokes that
you're telling them like i don't
support you know this never came from a
place of malice it just came from a
place of
lazy and untalented you know i mean so
just trying to tell a joke
that you know people will [__] laugh
at which isn't enough anymore i think
you really have to think it through more
but
um uh [__] i was gonna i was gonna make
i was gonna say something oh yeah this
was gonna say about grouping people
together right
like if i'm in america right and i meet
someone from arizona
i don't give a [__] but if i'm in
germany
and i'm in a bar and i meet someone from
arizona i'm like oh [__]
i'm american holy [__] you know we have
so much in common
right here yeah but then you go in
you're like i don't even [__] where
you're from but you know what i mean
it's like that's what i'm saying it's so
weird
yeah like so the idea that like all
jewish people are like other jewish
people
it's only and all black people like
other black leaders all mexican people
it's only
it's only accurate when you look at it
from this enormous vantage point
but when you actually go down there
you're like oh you're from arizona i'm
from here we don't have that you know
whatever i don't
we're not yeah there's like when you
really start to think about how
like the things that what i'm saying is
when you look at someone and go
what are the things that you have in
common with a person they actually have
nothing to do with like the core things
like you might gloss over like well
we're both this but then it's really
these
other things it's it's other like you
know how you grew up where you grew
up or how you like what you think about
like you know like are you outdoorsy are
you indoorsy do you like
you know you do you like movies or you
hate movies are you into technology i
mean there's so
many the litany of things that you can
really look at to be like this is how we
are the same and this is how we are
different
go far beyond race and gender
but these are the two things that
recently
we just are like beating beating it down
be
beaten down the door and all they talk
about is those things and it's just
right it is uh dangerous and here's
where i was
really like kind of depressed on it
because like i'm definitely speaking
from my perspective
and i obviously people are gonna have
their thoughts with this my perspective
but
what what was very clear to me is
everyone's kind of feeling the same
basic
hopeless emotion because i was looking
at you know
the fact that ice cube now what he said
in response to kareem aldubar was
obviously somebody
he tweeted paid him like 30 silver coins
to say this was like
and that's just offensive to cream i'll
do jabar as a human being that he's
going to write something he doesn't
believe because of money i mean i think
the guy's fine but i was just sort of
like looking at the the reactions and i
was like man there's so much
[__] like people being like look nick
cannon said white people are vicious and
savage and then they'll post a picture
of like you know
some horrible picture from slavery as if
that proves like look they are vision
savage like
uh well i could post a picture of the
rwandan genocide if i wanted if you
wanted
to yeah idiotic game but it just made me
like be like people are playing this
incredibly i mean look slavery's as
savage and horrible as anything
but there's a lot of things that are
savage and horrible that all walks
people have done
so if you're gonna you know people are
using these things as a way to like
justify hatred right so i said to ashley
i'm like i [__]
hate this country right now like i love
this country but i [__] hate this
country and then i saw somebody write
so they fire nick cannon but the cops
who shot brianna taylor are not fired i
[__] hate this country and i'm like
man so crazy you know it's like what
what is true is right now people are so
frustrated
and right yeah but you hate this country
until you go to so you go to i love this
guy but
when i say please you go to france and
uh you know they're killing bus drivers
because the guy asked you to put a mask
on
no i mean it's that's and when i have
those little thoughts where i'm like
like literally the total tv show i have
on discovery is like about
loving american finding the good in all
these places and yet when you get lost
in this
you know i think it's like you get lost
in your you're in your apartment you
can't go out in the world you can't
interact with people
you're away from everybody you're
looking at social media it's nothing but
hatred hatred hatred and you're like
[__] man like things [__] people [__]
are
just like at each other's throats and
it's just like
the last thing you should be doing is
throwing gasoline on that fire
right you know and that's kind of the
whole point especially
yes i agree i understand i could i could
feel your passion about it and it's just
like totally get that i mean it's just
you know especially at a time when this
is supposed to be about
equality and justice for all because
that's what the movement is supposed to
be about and then for people that have
been so vocal
about this movement for them to just
casually
you know talk about jews in that way
jewish people in that way it becomes you
just it becomes like hey
like do you ever understand the point of
what you've been saying
you know like what i wanted to say to
when i was joking around with ashley is
because one of the things that
nick cannon and griff were saying was
like jews
stole being jews from black people black
people were the original jews
and jews stole that from them right now
this is a whole nother thing that i'm
not educated on
and i can't speak to but what i wanted
to say is well
how about you thank them for the six
million people who took one for the team
then
because uh that is a [__] absurd
thing to talk about that's like excusing
they were saying you can't be
anti-semitic if you are black and
smelly's like okay but
in terms of what the context of what
that has meant for 2000 years
you can be you know i mean that's not
really like you're just putting words on
things now
yeah and what does that and then what
does that have to do with what's
happening
now anything yeah it's like we're so
we're so like the
united states is isn't even 500 years
old you know
right right where are we like wait this
isn't yeah no
it's like what 200 yeah i'm saying like
there's there's plenty of
history and uh past that
that people are from all over the world
and so many things have happened i mean
people
dude you know what's fascinating too i i
grew up with uh my mom is like a super
duper like liberal hippie who basically
is the kind of person where any
indigenous person
african uh latin american you know
chinese any person who's like indeed
like whatever that means indigenous
whatever you know
the hippie people throw in that term she
always has like these like they're the
ones who are in touch with the earth and
they're
whole and they're and they're pure and
they're good and i'm reading this book
right now
it's [__] amazing book although i
don't know where it's called because
it's on ashley's kindle but it's all
about the
the indian wars in the american west and
what they talk about is
the indoor indians the whole weird thing
was the white people
created this idea that indians were
only violent when it came to white
people and so
the way that they approached him was
like if white people do this and that's
how it is what they didn't take into
account is these tribes have been
warring with each other for thousands of
years
and we're built around warring societies
you know
so it's just sort of like it's this
fascinating thing we're like
dude humanity is a dark beast
you know our our worst impulses to
divide ourselves up it wasn't like
texas first the indians it was like
those indians were fighting each other
the whole time
you know like that's this sort of need
to
section ourselves off and and and only
this i mean it's it's like this really
tragic flaw in in the human species
you know and ma'am and in mammals
actually i should say in all mammals
oh that actually that would probably be
the first actually if we had if we have
to count what we have in common on the
planet yeah we'd be mammals
we're a mammal and then we're human you
know we're
you know it's like you know this but
this thing about it's funny that you say
this you know about the
you brought this up about ice cube and
nick cannon saying these things
and then i think about how they changed
the washington redskins name
but that was something that we just we
just were fine with for so long
why were we fine with it it's
unbelievable yeah i know but
in the same way that people are fine
with yeah what you're talking about
right now about why isn't anybody saying
anything about
this stuff about the about jewish people
we we become
programmed to think that like only you
know the squeaky wheel gets the noise
it gets the uh what is that the squeaky
wheel gets the speaky wheel gets the
grease yeah
so i mean i i feel like we're all
oh we're all culpable yeah we're all
clubbable i mean i remember seeing a
first person example of that in uh
growing up i used to always say like if
somebody screwed you over i'd say oh you
got
gypped you know i never occurred to me
what that meant like you got gypped i
just say
and then i remember i was with some kid
one time in high school and he said oh
man i got totally
jude i was like what the [__] you can't
[__] say that
you know i was like [__] and then and
then i was like well gypsy well that's
the same gypsies you know what i mean
who also got slaughtered in the
holocaust
so it's like i didn't even realize i was
doing the exact same thing yeah you know
and and i and that's like the problem
with like
life is that like you know there's
probably plenty of things nick cannon
has said
that are great and there's probably
plenty of great things he's done for his
community
for [__] you know just people like
right like nick cannon's clearly a smart
guy
right so but everybody has like
good and bad impulses and it's like this
really [__] weird
weird thing that i don't even know what
my point is but just like like you're
saying is like
yeah we're all culpable we're all
victims and oppressors
that's the reality and that's kind of
what jameel hill's article was when she
was saying
just because african americans have been
so much the victim of racism doesn't
mean they're
desensitized to also being racist being
racist yeah
a hundred percent and that's like a
weird com that's like
for some reason that's a dichotomy that
is like yeah
like isn't really said you know what i
mean but like just because you've been
abused and that's not about black white
anybody
if you've been abused doesn't mean
you're not gonna go abuse somebody
like it's just a sad reality human
beings aren't able to like
like i said in the beginning put
themselves in other people's shoes even
if they've been in those shoes
yeah you know it's pretty weird well you
know it's it um
i often i always like to ask people the
question
like if somebody did a really
good thing or really bad so if somebody
did something bad
does that mean they're a bad person you
know
um sometimes people some some people
depending on how bad it is you know like
can people make mistakes but in the same
way though
if somebody does something good one time
doesn't mean they're a good person
no it's like it's like we're case by
case we're living in the moment
each moment each moment you have to keep
proving yourself
because one act can take it all away
and the sad thing is one act that was 12
years ago can take it all away
yeah but you know like to echo what you
said is like
it's look i think you know
some okay because first of all gandhi
probably the most famous person in
regard to peace outside of martin luther
king
in his biography admits to beating his
wife at one point in his life
right crazy right and that is a fact
that's something he's
all right so i think there's a
complexity
to humanity and so anytime someone says
white people are are superior black
people are spirit
jews are conspiracy any time anyone says
something cut and dry
gay people are going to hell straight
people are not you know it's
[__] because life is not simple and
so when you hear
people expound like all black men are
gods all white men are afraid of the sun
and that's like
this because this is what nick cannon
was saying anytime people say these big
things
all jews are the chosen people it's all
[__]
right because that's not actually how
anything works yeah and that should be
your first
red flag [__] full of [__] you know
and yeah dude
and gandhi was probably trying to he was
trying to rest be at peace and his wife
was probably
and a lot of people don't know was
that rice burned you know what i mean
gandhi's wife terrible joy it is here
yeah
hey well it's still a comedy podcast can
we can we do a bad joke
i'm sure i'm going to get a lot of
comedy fans off this podcast um no no
no no no it's not about that man i i
listen i understand you i felt that you
needed a neat a need to like come and
talk about these
this kind of this subject because it is
important right now to like really look
at this in a nuanced way of like hey
you know what is social justice and what
is
equality and how should that look in in
yeah and it doesn't look like the words
nick cannon was saying it doesn't look
like the words ice cube was saying
that doesn't look like equality and it's
like how are we really going to get past
this how are we really going to be
better
unless we're doing it for all people and
if i could just
end on one thing i would say because one
thing i'm noticing
when i look at um just twitter timelines
and all that [__] is that like
you know it it seems like there's a lot
of obviously
there's a lot of different education
about let's just keep it on the subject
of jews right between the different
races right now
so i would just say to anybody who has
these ideas
really try to educate yourself on a
broader spectrum of who jews are
because i remember i didn't grow up
around black people at all i grew up in
a town that was probably
65 hispanic and then three jews and then
the rest
white people right out in the country
and i remember we went on a trip one
time
to san francisco and went to the museum
in our and our docent was like this uh
black guy and i remember us like all the
kids were like are you a basketball
player you look like a basketball player
and he had a good attitude about it he
goes no you kids just don't know who
black people are
you know what i mean he was it was funny
it was like that's true you know as you
grow up you're like okay we were in
sixth grade
i would just say that like if you have
an idea of what like jews are this isn't
that like
just be aware reach out to some jews
like be aware that like i grew up like
the only black people i knew were
[__] rappers and actors and athletes
because that's where i grew up
you know what i mean like you probably
don't really know
right so actually get to get to know
people and i know it's such a stupid
cheese dick thing to say but it's like
no it's not
never you will never be disappointed the
more you get to know people on a human
level
i don't care who they are you will never
be disappointed because you will find
that you have
i'm as much saying we're different we
have so much in common you know
and then and this is hilarious and i'm
really glad i was able to work that bit
out
no no no i i agree with you man i agree
with you 100
i just what i'm just saying is like we
shouldn't just use
what the point i was just trying to make
earlier is that we can't just use the
first
the first three things as as a way of
being like grouping us all together
because we're so much more than that you
know right and you and and
on that list of things that we're so
much more you're gonna find out that
other people have those things on their
list too
not just one group like you know like if
like if i had a hundred things on a list
that make
people the same and you took off
human race and gender there'd still be
97 other things on the list
that make us the same so let's not just
harp on that one and then you wouldn't
take like you know
like people from califor like are all
people from california are they all the
same
no you know you know it's like it's it's
a ridiculous thing to say it's such a
broad thing
and so i think that being jewish is such
a broad thing for you to be like well
all jews are the same
i mean it's it's ridiculous all right so
if you find
yourself thinking yeah if you find
yourself thinking those thoughts or
perpetuating any thought like that about
any group based on what you've
read or heard or you know because you
like this guy or this speaker
just be aware that probably you're wrong
you know that things aren't that simple
it's to me like did you live in the
dorms in college you go to college yeah
do you remember when the question they
asked the dorms what kind of music do
you like was the main question you're
like
that's not gonna determine if i [__]
hate my roommate like that's the [__]
stupidest question ever how about like
do they have to sleep with [__] weird
white noise like my roommate
you know i mean like yeah roommate was
such a lunatic
he had to put on loud white noise and he
put i swear to god a box over his head a
cardboard
box that he had fashioned to keep out
all the light
and you know i don't give a [__] what
someone's music choice is if they're
doing weird [__] like that
you know i mean it's the same thing like
what were we deciding but if that guy
again
again though and if he was a jew i would
have loved him no but i'm saying that's
what my point is like what if that guy
was jewish
like then does it mean i would have
hated him just as much that's what i'm
saying
it's like there's other things there's
other reasons to that well that's
my point i'm trying to make is there are
so many other reasons
to dislike people
[Laughter]
people are disagreeable and it's not
because of their race gender or sexual
orientation
or you know you know what i mean it's
not
those aren't that's what i like about
the comedy store like i
have i feel like friendly with everybody
there on the same level and i feel like
the status is purely who's funnier you
know like i have
no feeling other than that you know it's
funny you say that i was thinking about
that today it's so funny you say that
because i was thinking about i wanted to
talk to you about this anyway what we've
already talked about i was thinking
about the things that i wanted to say
and i i said them to you
but like when i think about the things
that say we
you and i have in common you know those
things are
so like being men i wouldn't even
mention that
you know right being human i wouldn't
mention that you know
you're looking exactly like my dad it
would be like there's so many other
things that
you know that are it's like again it's
just more nuanced
you get you go deeper and like and as
comics that's the one thing we have in
common first is that oh
we're people that want to be comedians
and then there's a whole litany of
things on that list that
that makes us you know the same and
different
and it's like it's so much more than
just race and
and gender and i just feel like i feel
like the world is
caught up in race and gender and they
make it all about that
and it's like yo [__] you man there's so
much more going on in this world right
now
and you're and you're making it about
this and it's just it's it's not right
it's it's exhausting it's [__]
exhausting and it's like yeah it rings
false you know what i mean and it's like
it's like when you see a comedian and
all they talk about
and look i've been guilty of this myself
plenty of times
all they talk about is their their race
boring and it means they're not very
good and they're not really actually
thinking too much
because they're just taking the easiest
[__] identifiable things
you know yeah well i don't necessarily
agree with that but
hack you know i don't necessarily agree
with that i mean i think that you know
we
i think that comedians forget that
they're supposed to be entertaining
um and it's supposed to be entertaining
to the people that are in the crowd not
to
other comedians i think that comedians
worry too much about what other
comedians think
and most comedians aren't funny most
comedians are
are like it's a small percentage of
people that are really making it
like in the way that they everybody
thinks that they want to but we forget
that we're entertainers and
there is you know i don't i don't mind
um um the
blue collar guys speaking to their
audience
in a way that they speak to their
audience i don't i don't mind that
either i'm just saying that like
i'm just saying you should be able to
talk about variety like i'm gonna
respect a comedian if they can
make a variety of topics funny as
opposed to if they can only make
one topic funny right but if you can
talk about one topic
for a extended period of time there
still is an art form
and making that entertaining and
hilarious even though you're just
talking about this one thing i mean it's
just more
like like we just disagree on what we
think uh you know
and that's the thing that makes comedy
so thrilling to do
is like there's you know there's so many
different ways and approaches there's no
right or wrong way in my opinion
um but anyways anyways you know we've
been talking a long time and
i just i'm glad you came on and talked
about this i mean i think it's important
and
the main message we're trying to get
across right now is that you know it's
equality and justice
for everyone that's what black lives
matters
means and it's and it's just we're
it's a lightning rod the black people
it's a lightning rod because it's so
visible
of what happened like that george floyd
tape changed everything
because and people and these things have
been taped before but there was
something about this one
there was something about this one that
i think woke up the other people in the
world to go
oh okay this is actually
worse than we thought or we didn't
realize how bad it was
and this can apply to everyone and let
me let's do something about it
but we have to make sure that we do it
for everybody like anyone who
feels the need to say like always better
after something is like an idiot because
i never
in a million years would think anyone
who's saying black lives matter is
implying
black lives matter more than those than
chinese life only an idiot feels the
need to say that i mean in a million
ways i don't say that
it's just sort of like i it's almost
like that's where the confusion comes
because it's so without saying that if
someone says black lives matter they're
talking about equality they're obviously
saying black lives matter
but what they really mean is of course
obviously all lives matter like duh
right you know what i mean like that's
like yes i saw that
you're like wait a minute it just means
black lives matter too
you know right but it's like i thought
we were all on board that's that was
right
right right and that's the that's the
passion you feel for it's like listen
you were on board with this as a jewish
person you're like hey
i'm on board with this and then when you
see
these kind of things being said about
jewish people you're like hey aren't we
on board with equality what's going on
here where's all the outrage where's all
the
where's everybody where you know where's
all the like where's all the people who
were trashing
who are like like like all the energy
for me too
should be the same energy for this kind
of stuff too
it's like me in the elevator i'm pissed
at people not wearing a mask
but if i'm not wearing a mask don't
[__] give me a hard time about it you
know what i mean it's like
that's that's basically what it all is
yeah man so we need we need we need
what i'm saying is like all the outrage
that's out there for things
channel your energy towards let's make
sure we call out all the injustice not
just the the selective
or the ones that are cool to get likes
you know or the ones
you know it's like the one that i feel
like sometimes the black lives matter
has become a fad
and and it's and that part of it has
taken over
for the point and the point is justice
inequality
and i that's the part that i don't like
about social media but at the same time
excuse me at the same time it's like we
got to get the message out so if the
message is out it's still great
there are there are changes happening
but it's not enough you know they
because it you know they changed the
redskins name for the washington
redskins it's no longer gonna be called
that
so that to me is a branch of hey this is
how we're showing like hey we don't want
this kind of stuff happening anymore
so we have to it has to apply to
everyone right and as a final thought
i am 100 against this idea of cancel
culture
right so if nick cannon truly doesn't
feel the way that this came across
and can actually equivocate that which
would be amazing to figure
out based on some of the things they did
kind of get out of it or even come back
in the year and say look man
i did some other research i met some
people and not to say not just do like i
met with a holocaust survivor now i'm
i'm done with that you know like
actually great he should get another
shot and you know what he has a huge
platform so he doesn't need anyone to
give him a shot probably but i'm just
saying that like i don't believe that oh
cancel someone they should never but i
mean like if someone is on the wrong
side of something
they should do the personal work in
every aspect of well
and that's why i was a person and that's
why i'm against cancer culture because
yeah it takes away from it takes away
from accountability
like it takes away like candace uh
candace uh what's her name um
owens no no no no the comedian you know
thompson yeah yeah she has a great joke
about shame
and it's important like we've removed
shame from from the
from the world because we just want to
cancel people and remove them we want to
destroy their lives
as opposed to them making them
accountable for their actions and having
them come and be like
hey i made a mistake this is what
happened and then we go okay good
we'll give you another chance no people
are just kind of like they they're
caught up in like no we have to remove
people from society
we have to make sure that they never do
whatever they were doing again
who's that for it's not for anybody and
it's not realistic because
as a as a as a son as a brother
as a person in a relationship right now
with somebody like as
a friend i've gotten better and starts
and stops throughout my whole life right
we grow we grow we grow and then on the
most
and so on our beliefs and everything
like look growing up we used to play
this game called smear the queer when i
was a kid
everybody played it whereas whoever had
the football was the queer and you would
try to tackle them
it was horrible and it never occurred to
me it was bad until my dad was like you
guys shouldn't say that's terrible to
say
right but i was like you know it's 13 i
was like i didn't think about it right
yeah you don't even realize
didn't even think about it so now as i
grow up it's like yeah you realize how
[__] horrible that is and your ideas
about all these you know
things and that and that's just a small
microcosm of everything
things that i said when i started
commenting i don't agree with things
that i said
[__] three absolutely saying i know i
i think about that too it's like you
know we go damn
what did i say so people need yeah and
if you don't give people the chance to
like grow like god i wouldn't love
nothing more because i love ice cubes
[__] music
dude i have gotten two of his albums
memorized i still play him i [__]
enjoy it right i still
i mean [__] i could still play r kelly
to be honest with ian still enjoy some
of it but like if somebody like i mean
r kelly's irredeemed i would say in my
lifetime maybe in the in
in the heavens they could figure it out
or whatever but a guy like ice cube
where it's like
[__] i like this guy as a performer i
would love nothing more
than to see him be like man i kind of
yeah i could see where i kind of got a
little
that was wrong you know and i and i see
it from a different way i would love
that i would love that
you know i mean and i would completely
you know i'll watch the next are we
there yet
but it's just like yeah it's it's that
kind of like
if people are given the chance to grow
and change and i think kevin hart said
it the best
like when he was kind of going through
and all that [__] then people will take
all this stuff
seriously and not just be like oh here
the mob goes again cancel them no
it's more serious than just cancel them
right yeah it's more like
hey this sentiment is incorrect
and and you need to work on that and
we'll let you do that
as long as you're willing to work on it
you know
well said brother well said um let's
talk about it for another 40 minutes
no that's great man i appreciate you
coming on uh you know it's these weird
times i mean sometimes i'm from being
just 100 honest sometimes i just
like i i i go what is the point of doing
this podcast anymore like i feel like
that sometimes but i just i guess i feel
like that about a lot of things that i'm
doing where you just go
the world just like it didn't even give
us a chance there was no landing gear
there was no announcement like it just
was like
everything stopped and then like we got
a little bit of hope
and then there then they go up look at
the numbers we have to shut it down
again so then you're just kind of like
where are we and where are we going so
i appreciate when someone like yourself
comes on i get reinvigorated for it
and here we are i'm still trying to put
out content and like i say
make sure you guys go to discovery go
and watch uh what's it called small town
small town yeah small town throw down
small town throw down because
you know if you watch it and put some
comments tweet at discovery you're gonna
like it
it's unfortunate for mo that we're in
the middle of this uh pandemic because
he can't go to small towns and do small
town stuff because you can't be around
people
i can't even throw i can't even throw
down so um and um
yeah so this has been more i appreciate
you having me on man i i uh
you're a friend that i always enjoy
getting to talk to
and uh i've known you since i moved to
l.a i know actually forever
actually the first time we met was in uh
in new york
uh for our half hour we did our half
hours at the same time no no
lively gotham that's what it was live at
gotham yeah wow and it's weird man it's
like
[__] guys like you and theo and stuff
like i'm like i've known you guys for
[__]
ever yeah that was two that was 2008.
yeah i mean that's crazy so but anyways
i remember you you had to you had to
sign up for sag and then like
you [__] you ended up not getting any
money from your check because you had to
put all the money into your check wasn't
it i mean yeah it's crazy
yeah it's like it's like wha i hate even
now you get a j let's say you get like a
job and then they go oh you got to pay
your dues and the dudes are like four
thousand dollars you go what
i i'm losing money doing this job i
don't care how good your agents or
managers are
anytime you see their fee you're like
what the [__] are they getting that for
you know what that would be that'll be
part two when i have mo on again but
everybody this has been mo mandel and
this is riffin with griffin so make sure
you subscribe
share and if you want to watch me game
i'm on error griffin gaming on twitch
daily
uh you can find mo down below all his
information will be below you can find
him on
twitter and instagram and uh and
wherever else he is
and i appreciate you coming on and
thanks again yeah man thank you
[Applause]
[Music]